here you displayed two hours of Tom
Clancy's Ghost Recon break point and it
kind of sounds like a 1.5 sort of
upgrade yeah I think what are the
biggest takeaways from you know spending
a lot of time with this game is it feels
a lot like you know the division sequel
to the original division it's not a
drastic departure from the wildlands
formula but more of an improvement on a
lot of the mechanics and specifically I
think wildlands was a little bit too
casual a little bit not enough of a
Ghost Recon game a little bit too much
about [ __ ] around it's a bit harder
for sure there's a lot more things you
have to to manage him when you're
fighting in the game but there's also
anyway I think the community might be a
little bit split on this I also started
seeing a lot of loot systems coming in
this build that I'm not sure they talked
about in the past
yeah and they wouldn't tell you much
when you ask them right yeah so I
definitely fought some tough enemies
that had levels over their head we
definitely picked up loot and there was
colors it was like blue or purple or
white so I liked that for the reason
that in Ghost Recon wildlands you
immediately knew where most of loot was
on the map when you started that game
and that just encourage you to not
necessarily play the game just to go
from point A to point B trying to
collect things yeah it kind of ruin the
immersion of it and then it kind of
leads us to another point where you're
saying we explore the explorations a bit
more natural this time around you aren't
looking at your map finding the areas
you want to go it's more like Far Cry in
a sense we just kind of stumble into
these missions in this demo it seemed
like we I mean they they planned our
route but we did also seem to run across
a lot of random events in the world like
convoys and people just sticking around
you would sort of so what we do is we
would go to a bivouac the bivouacs are
not originally thought of a black could
be anywhere but it turns out they're set
points on the map so they're more like
your chequebook you can't like set up a
bivouac you have to actually go to that
location yes where you can do things
like craft med packs and things of that
nature right so yeah there is crafting
particularly there's there's med packs
and stimpacks and you know have more
levels of injury in this game so if you
take a nasty hit it'll knock a piece off
of your life bar that stays permanently
locked out and you need to take a
medpac to get that life bar back and
then use stimpacks to get the actual
health back did it take a while like if
you got hit and UN to heal we would you
have to make sure you were in a safe
area where you could yes I met ade
definitely and the drones that we fought
were some of the most aggressive enemies
I've seen like wild lands some of the
enemies in this world like the wild
lands enemies but the drones were
incredibly aggressive they would come
after you from both the air and the
ground and they're they're basically
like killer killer Jeeps with guns and
like killer drones with guns some of the
drones were very zippy they'd do
backflips and fly around so there was
once or twice where if you if you did
not do the stealth from the game you
just get annihilated by drones yeah it
seems like stealth is more of a focus
this time right so I like to mess with
devs and on the first mission they tried
to make us do it stealth and I just
immediately pulled out a rocket launcher
blew up a vehicle and went loud and for
the whole rest of the next couple of
missions I was almost always out of ammo
I was constantly scavenging and trying
to trying to get it I was sort of
outgunned in a couple different
situations it's not that you can't play
this loud and and fast and aggressive
but it's hard to you'll you'll run out
of ammo very quickly and you'll find
yourself getting surrounded by certain
very aggressive enemies yeah that's one
thing they want to make a point of is
that you're not the hunter you're the
hunted this time and that lack of ammo
and resources kind of feeds into that
did you prefer that do you wish you
would have had enough resources the last
year or do you like the fact that you
were scrounging and it was nice that
they dial the guy like me back because
my tendency and I think a lot of
people's tendency is to just go around
not caring at all and you know this is
the Ghost Recon series they've come a
little bit too far in the casual
direction and I like that they're
dialing it back a bit so again it's not
that you can't do it it's just much
harder to do as more consequences yeah
there's also some very very tough
enemies so there's some end game enemies
we saw we fought at the kima the very
large drone and that large drone in kind
of loot fashion is guarding a tower that
has better loot in it but they've
indicated I don't know what level they
pushed us up to for this demo but they
indicated that you would get through the
game
and there would be those endgame bosses
that you have to fight it's for better
loot Oh
also in the loot front you can equip it
now so like you can you can earn a
ghillie suit or a helmet but it has
stats on it so maybe a little bit more
than that what they've done with
Assassin's Creed ok where there's a
little there's also a little bit of an
RPG system in there and that's nice
because it drives you to collect things
and those things make you a better
player as opposed to or more powerful
player as opposed to just collecting and
getting bored did it so when you fought
say you went up to an enemy who was not
armored or anything was that still like
aim for the head he's gonna drop or was
it more like a division where you might
have to sing quite a few bullets into
him before he drops because that is not
something I'd like to see in a Ghost
Recon game that's a good question I
think they kind of took a middle ground
approach the drones arm or the division
ask kind of enemies where you can they
do get a little spongy and you have to
put a lot of damage into them but
they're pretty committed to people being
people and there's a heavy enemy but you
could you know we were sink shot and you
could you could just basically pop this
helmet off and then take them down and
one ever played co-op or we sit so low
we were playing with four players ok on
that note I don't know what this game is
gonna be like solo and wildlands was
always fun with friends and then you had
your AI squad may it's great that they
were not that great yeah not very useful
yeah well except for sync shotting in
this game playing by yourself might get
a little bit lonely because you don't
really have anybody else but there are
things you can do like you can't talk to
people there's some dialogue trees they
don't know interesting they don't seem
to have any impact on the game
necessarily more just figuring out the
backstory of lower characters etc yeah I
will say the main villain is very
interesting Cole Cole Walker Jon
Bernthal he feels more like a far cry
villain if he feels like more like one
of those digging into insanity Far Cry
type of plots I found him to be way more
interesting than I can even remember I
mean it was like a bunch of drug lords
last time I ran he was he was memorable
and honestly I think he's gonna be a
pretty good character if they if they
develop it there was a cutscene that I
can't show
but he was he was with nomads just
casually like killing people and having
a conversation in the past they're just
like talking talking shop like it's
regular life but they're in a sniper's
nest like shooting people
so everything yeah well that's it you
saw Ghost Recon breakpoint it comes out
October 4th 2019
how are you feeling about it you excited
I really was a huge fan of wildlands I
wanted them to be a little bit more
Ghost Recon than they were last time
around and I think we're gonna get that
in this game so if you if you really
enjoy violins and you want more of that
game with better mechanics that's what
this is good yeah the loot system makes
me a little nervous I don't know if I
necessarily want that in a Ghost Recon
game but I'm curious nonetheless but for
more on e3 2019 stay tuned to game spot
[Music]
you